Jordan B Peterson has unveiled his  Twitter suit it's quite literally a suit  featuring a tie with Elon musk's face  all over it it's really strange and I  don't really understand what's going on  with Jordan Peterson but it's pretty  weird and as we've tracked over the last  year or two these strange Twitter  outbursts including one that targeted me  following by followed by numerous  announcement that he was getting off of  Twitter and then he's back and he's even  Wilder and wackier than ever I don't  really know what's happening with Jordan  Peterson but I do know that increasingly  my followers many of whom are young men  who used to regularly email me about you  don't understand Peterson he's really  brilliant he's really smart he's doing  great things to help I'm getting fewer  and fewer of those emails so I don't  know if his luster is starting to fade  or what's going on with Peterson but  seems quite unstable